ah the complex stance of public transit
shall I place my foot there can I glance
here do I put my bum there you may think
you have free will but you're following
the dance cues of the guys and gals who
actually design the cars the engineers
every public transit agency in the world
spend serious time thinking about what
their cars will look like and why it's
not time wasted because every minor
decision they make about design impacts
everything from user experience to how
many people can comfortably ride the bus
or train soon residents traveling
between Oakland and San Francisco will
have a totally new experience the Bay
Area Rapid Transit agency known
affectionately or unaffectionate as Bart
will be rolling out new rail cars like
all good things it began with a litany
of complaints the single most common
comment we got was people wanted to see
adequate seating so that became a
guiding principle behind our design
there is no shortage of seating layout
options New York City is all about bench
style personal room nil but at least you
can squish more people in Bart went with
the opposite one of the things that we
noticed is quite often we saw a row of
people seated in the BART train subtly
leaning away from each other
reflecting the fact that most of our
riders ride solos and so we wanted to in
our design process to find some personal
space for the typical commuters that
observation lines up with other research
people hate sitting between strangers
they also hate being forced to make eye
contact with them the new BART cars
don't make riders do any of these things
in fact they were designed with
different sections for different types
of riders in mind for short tripperz for
long-haul commuters for cyclists for
those in wheelchairs designers also
choose the best positioning for standing
riders bart has new poles by the door
hang on short people there's one more
door per car now
so maybe riders will be less paranoid
about missing their stop Bart hopes the
redesign will allow more people to ride
on the cars it will also be an expanded
size to accommodate the ever increasing
passenger loads that our trains have
every train will be a 10-car train
that's going to and from San Francisco
during commute periods happy squeezing
riders